at least 44 people have been killed and
around 150 others injured in a stampede
at a religious gathering
attended by tens of thousands it
happened at mount marin
in the northern part of the country
where ultra-orthodox jews
were holding an all-night prayer and a
dance celebration
[Music]
this footage from social media shows the
scene shortly before tragedy struck
a densely packed crowd dancing
ecstatically
at the annual lacpa omer celebration
[Music]
authorities believe overcrowding is
likely to blame
for the fatalities and injuries
rescue workers say many of the dead were
either trampled to death
or suffocated
we just finished treating one of
israel's worst
disasters a terrible disaster of
people who came to celebrate lagma omer
and rabishimo
and unfortunately were literally trusted
[Music]
it was the first large-scale religious
gathering to be held legally since
israel lifted most coronavirus
restrictions
but despite israel's successful handling
of the pandemic
health authorities had warned against
holding a gathering of this size
the lag ba omar religious festival is
particularly popular with israel's
ultra-orthodox community israeli police
report nearly 100
000 people attended the gathering which
they say is four to five times as many
as should have been in location like
this
and from jerusalem i'm joined now by
journalist sami
sokol sammy tell us what more happened
here
yeah well this is an annual event and in
the previous years we've had
up to 200 000 people on the mountain
around for these festivities
but it seems that this year was a bit
different there were different
arrangements on the site
and this what is causing this stampede
that brought about to the death of 38
religious men all of them belonging to a
group which is known here as the tordot
arron
this is a group based here in jerusalem
an ultra-orthodox
group and they were kind of
told by by police to to leave the the
site
so as to enable other groups to come in
and we have to remember that
last night was a thursday night today is
a friday and
everything was done in a very hasty way
because of the upcoming sabbath
and as you've highlighted there i mean
the lag by omar it's considered to be
one of the most important in the
orthodox community could this have been
prevented
what went wrong
yeah well lag bahamur is it comes at no
no surprise this is a major event and
there's been thousands of
police there and what we see
is a mismanagement i would say most of
it is a kind of a mismanagement on a
local level
there were gates that were supposed to
be open
according to eyewitnesses who've been
speaking to the
to the media they've been saying that
certain gates were not open when they
were supposed to be open
emergency gates that the police force at
the time
did not realize the scope of this
of the tragedy of the upcoming tragedy
but we also have to remember that this
great
distrust between this specific uh
religious group
the tordota aron they are they regard
themselves as anti-zionists
and they often are in friction with
police and so we
already from the beginning we don't have
a good relationship
between this group and the police
and maybe this is also one of the
reasons that we saw what we saw
tell us a little bit more about um you
know in the context of what you're
saying
right there and also in the context of
what's happening on the ground
than with the challenges that the
authorities might be facing because we
understand that there are still people
on the mountain
um the rescue forces how do they handle
this now
yeah well you know the the rescue forces
uh once the the
the reports came in uh
they had the helicopters the air force
and helicopters
coming to the location evacuating the
wounded
to hospitals and the ambulances came
and everyone on this mountain were taken
out
and especially their trains were
operated
from the nearby towns so is to evacuate
everyone
and once this tragedy was known
there was you can hear the footage
actually it was in hebrew and in the
editions the community that speaks
yiddish
and they were told to leave the site and
everyone has been there by now has been
evacuated
but of course there will be a
investigation
and we're seeing this as a major
a tragedy that israel has not seen
for for decades i would say
sami sokol joining us with the very
latest thank you
you